joining us from the athletic as well as
fox sports is a man who initially broke
the news that jim harbaugh was thinking
about the nfl and it was a very real
interest and
as we saw the interest was real and then
i guess the interest was not maybe
mutual what at the end of the day with
harbaugh on the vikings and it's our
friend bruce feldman back here on the
rich eisen show how you doing bruce
i'm doing well rich good to be on with
you guys right there no problem right
back at you um so what happened with
harbaugh and the vikings best you can
tell
as best i can tell from the sources i've
talked to jim harbaugh went up
to minnesota with the expectation that
he was going to get an offer
to be the head coach there and people i
had talked to in the building were
convinced that jim harbaugh was going to
jump at it
um and then something over the course of
this extensive interview process and i
was told something seemed to gone wrong
around three o'clock and things took
things kind of sour
and i have not gotten a great answer on
what exactly that was
um that kind of turned things but he did
not get offered the job
and
is going back to michigan obviously um
and kevin o'connell is getting the job
so i don't know if it's necessarily
that
jim harbaugh is a strong personality
he's a different guy i don't know if the
leadership at the vikings looked at and
said i'm not sure we want to work uh
with him or feel like we i feel like it
would be best to work with him and i
think they looked at him and kevin
o'connell yes they both played
quarterback in the nfl but kevin
o'connell is a very different
personality
than jim harbaugh is and i think kevin
in his 30s compared to jim in his late
50s
no doubt jim harbaugh's had a ton of
success in a brief amount of time in
four years in the nfl
but i think for the vikings that just
seemed like a much more attractive
proposition and so so without an offer
jim harbaugh's back as the head coach at
michigan what are your sources saying
why harbaugh was interested in the nfl
is it based on the fact that michigan
cut a salary and that is something that
he just you know
put his put in his mind wouldn't forget
and decided that uh now would be the
time to to try the nfl what what
happened why now essentially i heard i
had heard rich that the relationship was
a little uh rocky there internally and i
think that had something to do with it
um and i think look if he was gonna
leave this was the time you and i talked
about this you know he just
just won the big ten for the first time
in almost 20 years they whipped the arch
rival all that stuff lined up well um
and then
you know everything i'd heard from
people closer was he still wants a
chance to make a run at winning a super
bowl and at 58 this seemed like a really
ideal time
but
the way the circumstance lined up and
the way it worked out in his interview
process with the vikings
i think if it's jim harbaugh and this is
also from talking to some people close
to jim was the expectation was jim
harbaugh is different than a lot of the
candidates he's not a first-time head
coach
he's been to a super bowl before he was
wildly successful as an nfl head coach
um
it was almost like it was expected if
jim harbaugh wants a job he's going to
get the job and that is not and that
certainly didn't play out this way this
cycle and i can't imagine it you know
like going forward because this was such
a
unique situation in terms of it played
out so publicly i know when
we talked about it or was it a month ago
or so and then it got more momentum as
as you know more dominoes fell it was
public he was talking about with
recruits guys on his staff were feeling
like jim's jim wants it he wants out
um
and you have his defensive coordinator
mike mcdonald leave after a good year to
go
to back to the ravens to run that
defense and allison so you have a big
vacancy on the staff you've lost a lot
of really good players
to the nfl off that playoff team so
we'll see because this is not a team
that has been at all active in the
portal either where almost everybody
else even you know alabama as good as
they are they they've got three terrific
players out of the portal michigan has a
bunch of holes especially on defense
you know we'll see how aggressive
jim harbaugh and this staff is going to
be going forward because i do think
there's a bunch of stuff that needs to
be smoothed out
um internally there well
what is it
i mean and and and i i know i'm asking
you multiple questions at once which is
a bad thing to do as a as a host but
i'll do it anyway
but um did you say he mentioned the
recruits
i'm thinking of going to the nfl like he
was open on that process
my understanding was and i think it was
reported by one of the recruiting sites
in michigan that he was including with
like one of the top recruits they have
coming in was open with his family and
transparent and if that's the case i
mean good for him that he was
that he was because that's not the norm
when it comes to stuff happens around
recruiting so
i think because of that i think
you know a lot of people were like oh
he's definitely gone um and it didn't
play out that way and i don't know if
this feels like the costanza scene from
seinfeld where he just shows back up to
work and
acts like it's completely i think that's
actually a larry david bit originally
right well actually larry david did it
in real life after he was fired from
saturday night live and he put it in
there but as you know the michigan
football program isn't the human fund
so
you know how does this work man how does
it how does it work now like what are
they going to do to make sure that
recruits know he's not going anywhere
ever again i mean what happens
i don't know if you can you know i don't
know if you can really do anything
assurance-wise no matter what you do in
a contract at some point look if jim
harbaugh at 58 is going to you know he's
not going to get any younger obviously
but like if he is going to draw more nfl
interest to the point where people are
going to hire him away
jim harbaugh is probably going to have
have gotten his team back into the
playoff for more it's not like if he
turns around and goes eight to four
people are going to say it was a you
know it was more of a fluke or a one-off
or whatever so i think if i'm michigan
i'm like i want
him to be an nfl commodity because if
that's the case he's doing something
right and if he's not
you know then we ride the jim harbaugh
kind of roller coaster a little bit but
like
you know i i think the first orders of
business for them are
you re you know i obviously have to
patch up things internally with the
staff probably with some of the players
i mean we'll see how that works out see
how it goes forward with i'm sure
publicly he and the aed will will try to
put a positive face on this and then
he's got to find a new defensive
coordinator um i thought that was you
know mike mcdonnell was
trying to be a terrific hire but they
have got to
they're going to have to be active in
the portal and get some transfers to uh
you know it's like coming out of the
spring at the very least when we expect
another wave of influx in the portal um
because that roster has some holes that
they're going to try to repeat as big
ten champs but i mean he did
come up michigan did if i'm not mistaken
what ranked eighth in recruiting yeah
eighth or ninth yeah i mean it's a good
class but again i mean did they lose
anybody based on on on the last few
weeks that you can tell
you know and that's one thing that i
think got overblown because the optics
weren't great that he was doing it on
signing day but they were basically done
i mean jim harbaugh giving the staff off
what i was told is they had a junior day
on sunday which and maybe there was two
dozen
prospects there i i think the the
biggest challenge uh rich is going to be
you know hugh ajabo aiden hutchinson dax
hill
ross you have an incredible really good
incredible year and kids that are
incredibly good players who are gone
hassan haskins
you know like look you're gonna get
ronnie bell back the two quarterbacks
you know they should be better with more
time in the system the offensive line is
a bunch of guys back
but they gotta rebuild the defense and i
think that is the first order of
business there because remember you know
like this was before last year this was
the achilles heel
of that team when they played really
good teams and so i think that's
look it's got to be back it's got to be
business as you not it's got to be back
to work and i think right now you know
now that he's going full you know
enthusiasm unknown to mankind now has to
be with an energy because the energy
of the other people who are trying to
make it to the playoff
is at an incredibly high level because
they are so active you know with the
portal because schools
you know to some degree or others are
getting very engaged how they are using
nil
as a as a recruiting you know appeal to
to build their to stock their rosters
and i think
michigan is is going to have to get more
up to speed on some of those fronts
right now bruce feldman here on the rich
eisen show let's uh let's move on to
texas a m first things first do you know
who sliced bread is have you ever met
sliced bread
i have not okay you so i have not so
it's like the deep throat of uh college
football reporting um are you all like
looking around for for sliced bread
right now because sliced bread got some
run yesterday
no you know the sec
west is wild right now in terms of
there's there's a little three-headed
rivalry and lane kiffin's got his hands
in in lsu's you know like ear and his
fingers in lsu's eye right now between
what you know he has definitely stirred
it up he stirred it up on brian kelly's
you know little
gyrations on the videos nice stirred it
up and really wound up jimbo fisher and
jimbo fisher
punched back yesterday and
i think this is probably stuff that greg
sankey the commissioner of the league is
probably not thrilled about because
what you're saying or what you're
talking about is also you know like this
is the kind of thing where
it speaks to the you know it speaks to
under the table stuff that now everyone
just assumes is over the table and it's
fair game because of the nil aspect of
it so now the conversations and the
rumblings and the and the allegations
and the innuendos are full force
and
you know back in the summer i did a big
story for the athletic about one coach
is just basically saying this was what
it was going to be like that it was like
hey i don't want to hear to tell the
booster these boosters i don't hear you
guys complain that you lost we lost so
and so from our state or from our region
you guys had the chance you could pony
up and you could do this
and
i think
you know people are being kidding
themselves that they do not think some
some very
um
aggressive recruiting
is not going on involving a lot of
players what do we mean here so
what like because again the accusation
is a slush fund
that very uh rich um benefactors for the
school are putting in and basically
telling the kids this is going to be
your pot of money and will decide how
much you get based on your performance
is that
is that literally what is being thrown
out there and does something like that
do you think exist anywhere
i don't know i mean i think it's i do
think it's irresponsible to put it out
there because you know what people are
going
if you use this framework right jimbo
fisher just landed the the highest rank
recruiting class in the history of 247
sports basically in the history of
modern college football recruiting and
he did it after a team that just went
eight and four you know it's not like
this is alabama or this is georgia doing
it um
i i think the the the part that jimbo
has a point about is like
if if other coaches are pointing the
finger it's like well other coaches are
getting similar caliber recruits so it's
like oh it's only working for these you
know only these only this particular
school
is in the dirty pool um
you know like i think people are naive
if they think oh this school is doing it
and these other schools aren't as aren't
as as active in it i i think there's a
lot of stuff
that is going on that is going to be
hard for the ncaa to police
and whether it's to the degrees of the
of the slice bread uh
you know talk i don't know if i would go
that far with it but i do think there's
a lot of things that it's going to be
hard for the mca to get out in front of
and that's not saying that a m is doing
it and other places aren't it's not
saying that you know no one is no one
outside the sec is doing it i just think
that right now this has become
more of an open season on how this is
working
in a bunch of places
bruce feldman here on the rich eisen
show and so
the the process that i guess brian kelly
was utilizing to
do do we know what the genesis of the
dancing with the recruits was like i'm
i'm being genuinely uh serious here
because these are these are conscious
choices that that big programs are
making to make um to make i guess what a
cool atmosphere come hang with us we'll
dance we'll have fun we'll make videos
together or brian kelly is
doing things that he would never have
done or imagined to have done you know
in the stade
um shadow of uh of you know rudy and and
and and notre dame that um
that that
the kid he's dancing with eight million
people
saw it went to alabama when it's all
said and done is that actually that
actually is what happened yesterday
yeah i mean the crazy thing on that so
so some of this some of the social media
fodder and some of these like you know
the brian kelly dance performances this
isn't the first one that he's done right
he's been at lsu the first time was with
uh walker howard who was a five-star
quarterback who had been committed to
lsu
and basically i guess asked brian kelly
he was like you know trying to convince
them to come up there and dance with
them this other kid who was a tight end
in state um
decided you know was doing it brian
kelly
went with it and
you know i think for a lot of people
they were like because of what you said
this was not like
it's always been kind of a wild quirky
silly guy and this was like wait a
minute the buttoned-up guy from boston
who was at notre dame
like all of a sudden now he is getting
his freak on in these videos at 60 years
old and you know a couple with that with
the
you know the the cr you know the
the bogus accent the family you know
whatever he did at the basketball game
in front you know on the microphone
where
you know i think it was a joke that fell
flat that the bit kept on going on but
because of the videos and that i think
people are like okay what is he doing
and
in the guise of it i think some people
at lsu are looking at going well the kid
the recruit saw that he got this thing
funny or not
silly or not got over 5 million views at
the time and it's like well if that
entices the kid to want to play and be
part of brian kelly's program
so be it you know we'll we'll be part of
it and
you know the fact that this kid ended up
leaving the state and going to say to
play i'm going to go play for nick saban
instead everybody's like wait a minute
brian kelly did that opened himself up
to ridicule
and then the kid doesn't even go there
it's kind of an egg on your face thing
now in in in fairness to lsu and brian
kelly brian kelly did get a five-star
linebacker a top 10 recruit to commit to
him you know an hour or two later i mean
that's the nature of recruiting sure i
feel like is one thing that blows up in
your face and the other thing you know
you know works out much better and you
know people only remember the
embarrassing stuff depending on what
perspective you have well i'm just
wondering what the metrics are and and
recruiting now i mean we're just talking
about you know money and and under the
table or over the table but we're
calling it nil or we're not
viral videos and things like that you
know and it just seems like the game is
totally changed and that we're watching
it change you know and we didn't even
talk about caleb williams doing what we
all assumed he was going to do the
minute lincoln riley left for usc he's
now at usc
you know what i mean like it's just
i feel like the game is totally changed
and we still don't know how it's changed
just yet well there's there has always
been a farcical nature i did a
recruiting book meat market 15 years ago
and there was a lot of just stuff where
you just kind of like scratch your head
and be like oh my god this is so
ridiculous
and because what it comes down to is is
grown men in this case a 60 year old but
often you know 40 50 60 year old men
um courting
16 to 17 year old
you know bmocs and stars in their
community and their families and and
maybe their girlfriends and whoever else
to try to woo them to their place
and
whatever they think works at the moment
whether it's
you know something that's definitely not
above board whether it's you know paying
them cash or doing you know
giving no-show jobs or whatever it is
or just being super goofy in the moment
because you think it's going to endear
you to somebody or you think it's going
to get you attention
um now because we have social media
there's all a footprint in this stuff or
a lot of there's footprint of a lot of
it and so
i think this is so you know it's already
so far down the road it's only going to
get more so
because some of this stuff works some of
this stuff is effective and
you know it's like i mean not to make it
a social commentary but you have a lot
of people who have like
millions of followers on social media
people aren't exactly sure why but they
have big followings and so
i think this
kind of
kind of dovetails with that where a lot
of players will end up going to sign for
school and who knows a year from now six
months from now they may transfer and go
someplace else i mean the crazy thing
with signing day is and this has gone on
to some degree but i think it's more
widespread now
is like just because somebody signed at
a school and didn't pick your hat a lot
of those schools are still going to keep
recruiting behind the scenes to get that
kid to leave and that's the kind of
stuff that is going on and i think
that's you know that's why the whole you
know this part of college football is
such a
you know i don't know jimbo fisher's
word such clown act there's there's a
real element to that
bruce feldman uh before i let you go
just a couple minutes on the terrific
article you wrote um joe burrow is in
the super bowl man and it's just two
years and two weeks after winning the
national championship and completing the
greatest quarterbacking season maybe in
the history of college football
and it feels like it's pre-ordained
because of who he is i'll give you the
floor on that bruce yeah i mean if if
you were like i was fortunate to be
around lsu especially like the last
couple of months of that season when he
led them to the national title within
meetings and around
you know every practice and anybody who
was there and had that perspective
you know like
you came away thinking joe burrow is
different and he just is i'm not at all
surprised that he has led the bengals to
a super bowl i'm a little surprised it's
happened this fast and without much of
an offensive line but
his intangibles are off the charts he is
as close
to a
a
coach on the field and a player that any
college football program would have ever
had
and so you know the story you're talking
about on the athletic it was a lot of
examples that speak to the intangibles
and it's like
you know look i'd be lying if i said i
thought josh allen was going to turn out
to what he's become i didn't think he
would be a superstar joe burrow was one
i was like i'm definitely banking on him
changing the bengals just because i what
i knew and what i had seen and heard
about him and i think for the people who
maybe are wondering you know like you
look at the stories you're like okay i
get it he's different and it's not to
say he doesn't have a lot of physical
tools because he's accurate he's a good
athlete but just
the competitiveness and everything else
and the belief he inspires
um you know he went over a program of
elite athletes who were like you know
they didn't know anything about him he
was a guy didn't win the ohio state job
because you know urban meyer you know
went with dwayne haskins instead of him
and to see what he's done i mean it's
the bengals and and nobody nobody's not
mocking or making fun of the bengals
anymore and they won't for probably as
long as he's wearing that wearing that
jersey
and it was urban meyer who said yeah you
can go right that was what happened
because ohio state didn't have room for
him right the buckeyes let him go right
yeah just exactly just asking how they
had a really poor 50 touchdowns 50
touchdowns yeah he had 50 touches but
joe burrow is bringing brian not just
the staff he is bringing like he was a
program changer for that now look you
know they had jamar chase they had a lot
of other dudes the system was you know
was good but it was like it was joe
burrows intangibles
and everything he brought
i think that was just it was a perfect
fit and it was a perfect timing and
you know it's not like i said if you are
around him you're like
i don't doubt him and i i'm not at all
surprised like this won't be a fluke the
bengals are going to be they're going to
be a problem for the nfl for a long time
as long as he's there bruce thanks for
the time greatly appreciate it great
stuff as always we'll chat down the line
always a pleasure thanks for having me
that's bruce feldman bruce don't call me
sliced bread feldman right here on the
recharger hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here